I am with a company called hello robot
and we'll talk a bit about the robot
we've developed and also a little bit
about some of the prior work I've done
uh first off Stanford Alum very happy to
be back uh it's been an institution uh
dear to my heart that's me back when I
was 18 and first got to campus and I
think that was not long after the Loma
Prieta earthquake so even a lot of the
campus was closed back then
um
and for the talk you know I went back
through my archives and tried to find
some of the old projects I've worked on
and also tried to think about you know a
Common Thread about some of the work
that I've done over the years and so you
can see various humanoids there's a
tensegrity robot there's a biped the
underwater robot with with Asama uh
collaborative robot arms for
manufacturing work with Google analysis
of robots and I think the Common Thread
is really around robots that work around
people and what that means for these
machines to interact with people and so
I want to talk a little bit about that
and I've sort of coined it as being sort
of humanizing robot design uh term I
just made up for this talk but so why
why is that important and for hello
robot in particular
you know we have this this caregiving
crisis that's about to happen across the
world right this is really uh our we
don't have enough people to care for the
older adults uh it really is a crisis
and if you think about someone who's
home alone unable to get out of bed
easily and doing something as simple as
getting up and getting a glass of water
getting some pills it can take a huge
effort and and this is going to be
commonplace this type of problem we
commonplace across the world very soon
and uh so it really is a place where
robots can help and I think we we have
an ability to and that we should help uh
but for today what I want to talk about
is what does it mean to do sort of
human-centric design for for robots
uh and one key aspect for me is really
participatory design which means to put
the stakeholders in the center of the
design process and really talk to them
and involve them so that we know that
what we create is going to meet their
needs and I I hope to highlight some
work that shows why that's so important
um and so to put the human experience at
the center of the design means to really
think about what it means for them to
have this machine in their in their home
and what's that experience for them is
it enjoyable does it bring value to them
is it frustrating and really think that
through carefully rather than building
the technology without an eye towards
that so today I'll talk about kind of
five areas which I think are really
relevant to this one is safety
particularly if we're working with older
vulnerable populations
one is Simplicity and it's very hard to
get to Simplicity but it really matters
in terms of product experience the
experience of the robot
affordability Which is less commonly
researched it's not part of academic
life as much but very important if you
want to have impact you want to get
these robots out in the world and scale
capability for us at hello robot you
know if it's useful it's exciting if
it's capable it's exciting we want these
robots to do meaningful work
and meaningful also means that for the
person it actually enriches their life
it makes their life better that brings
value in a very important way so I'll
highlight how these five areas have kind
of found a thread through my work and
with hello robot
uh let me just start with a quick
introduction to the company
we are based in the Bay Area Up in
Martinez California near Berkeley
uh I'll play this is a about a two
minute video it's a our product launch
video
that's my son Levi who's sitting in the
back there
he just waved
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
build it in Martinez California uh sell
it to research Labs internationally it
really is a platform for Innovation so
it's open source lots of great sort of
software apis and we're really
encouraging people to explore the future
of mobile manipulation with this
platform
and we've been seeing great Traction in
the community in terms of adoption
people building machine learning models
on top of it adding new hardware Etc
and uh successful launch we've won some
Design Awards with it a great growing
Community we have them all over the
world at this point and just starting to
see great Publications come out with it
as well
in that hello robot we really do take
seriously the sense of purpose with with
the robots I really believe that these
types of machines can improve life for
everyone and we also recognize this as a
massive undertaking and that we should
embark on this with the whole Community
to try to build this future together
so um let's talk a bit about safety
which I think is
uh it's a very difficult topic and
there's lots of Notions of what safety
is there's this ISO standard for it
which uh is uh really pertinent to a
robot-like stretch but in the end safety
is about
um you know controlling interaction
forces often it's about managing pinch
points Crush points lacerations toppling
and when we're talking about robots with
vulnerable populations we really have to
take it seriously and it's not not a
trivial topic I've done some work over
the years in safety uh notably a lot of
work with serious elastic actuators and
all different types of forms and
variants the main thing about this type
of actuator if you're not familiar it
puts the spring and series with the
gearbox what that does is it decouples
the effect of inertia of the motor and
that gearbox winding up and when it hits
someone it lessens that impact
effectively so that's a really nice
attributes it has some disadvantages of
around complexity uh the fourth
bandwidth position accuracy so there are
trade-offs there but they have found
their way into commercial applications
um you know at my company Mecca we took
the the work that I did at MIT built
humanoids like this one dreamer at UT
Austin uh and then you can see a video
here of one of the humanoids that we
built back in the early 2000s and that
robot everything is serious elastic
actuator including the hands the fingers
it really was fun to interact with very
compliant interactive it felt very
natural
since my company Mecca's found its way
into some commercial robots the Baxter
robot by rethink apptronic has a
humanoid using that technology now
there's actually an exoskeleton for
physical rehab that's using it so really
interesting technology with stretch we
didn't take that path and hopefully it
will illuminate a bit why so first off
for safety you know one thing I've
learned over the years is really you
have to take a systems approach you
can't just solve the component just the
actuator you have to think about the
whole thing so with stretch the thought
about how do we lower the overall Mass
to the manipulator how do we make it so
we're not making these massive uh
actuators to fight gravity so most of
the actuation stretches down on the base
and it really makes out that uh
manipulator to be very lightweight low
inertia makes it safer it's also because
it's a telescoping joint makes it very
intuitive people understand the motion
as it's happening you know a seven-off
arm it can do these complex planning
planned motions and people just don't
know how to interact with that and
becomes unsafe so really with stress we
really took safety as a starting point
from the full systems View and came up
with a very different type of design
uh of course a robot like stretch has
toppling hazards because it is
lightweight but it's got a small
footprint and so some static analysis on
the Tipping stability that we did uh
because it's simple kinematics we get
simple close forms expressions of that
and what we find is we can get
reasonable forces really the biggest tip
tipping Hazard is in in uh pooling can
pull itself over supporting a payload it
does fairly well but you know we can get
modest pulling forces at full height and
full extension and what that means is
that we can actually do reasonable tasks
in households we can't do everything we
can't open a refrigerator door up high
but we can open it down low for example
uh and still with despite all the
thought we put into safety there are
real hazards with a machine like this uh
toppling is is one of them falling down
staircases one so you really have to
still address this this issue in in home
settings
um and also once you get into autonomous
motion it comes very hard to say
anything uh definitively about what what
can happen and so you know we are still
working on how to think about safety
more long term for this product
um move on to simplicity
now this is a robot built at MIT it's my
PhD work a robot named Domo you can see
there all the stuff that I had in it and
dozens of actuators a dozen computers
um
probably five or six different cameras
super complex uh
it was a lot of fun to build it was also
you know very easy to stack up that type
of complexity you know we just bolted
one thing to the next and
um so so complexity is much easier to
get to than Simplicity often so there's
a cool machine but you know I've learned
from that to avoid this type of
complexity
um and one bit of work that came out of
MIT from Rodney Brooks's lab that I
really took inspiration from still do
is this uh this is Herbert it was um
had 8-bit microprocessors he was able to
navigate uh the the offices of the Mita
lab drive around find Coke cans pick
them up and take them back to a location
and it did all that with a very limited
computation and what they did is they
really matched the robot to the
environment they thought carefully about
where do you find Coke cans how do you
recognize those those features with
simple sensors and tune that whole
system to that one task and remarkable
what I could do back then and this
notion of affordances comes out of some
some writing by Don Norman which I
really find inspirational and so with
stretch we took that same approach
and we thought about
you know you know what is a home really
you know do we need to have a general
purpose humanoid in there how can we
design a robot that matches that home
and so homes have lots of flat surfaces
floors countertops table tops
and we thought well a lot of a lot of
what matters happens around flat
surfaces build a system that is really
well designed for that and maybe we can
simplify the overall design problem
so the nice thing that comes from that
things like surface wiping which is a
common task that people would like to
have done in a home becomes much simpler
it's almost trivial to do in this case
so this is autonomous wiping
and you can see a very simple plan
and so what could be a very hard problem
becomes a very simple problem
likewise overall just planning and
manipulation for the robot becomes
simpler one thing we put a lot of
thought into is where to put the camera
it might seem like a fairly simple thing
but we really wanted to give the robot a
good workspace a view of its hand while
it's manipulating a view down while it
was navigating and the the key thing is
you know our environments are built we
look at them from above often and too
often you see robots of the camera down
low looking up and that Viewpoint
doesn't do a give it the right
perspective you need to work in a human
environment and so with this robot
planning manipulation becomes a lot
simpler also because of the Cartesian
kinematics in the placement of that
sensor
uh also you know we really wanted to be
something that felt more like an
appliance you know some of these the
robots that are home robots weigh 400
pounds you need a truck with a lift gate
to move it this I really wanted it to
feel more like a rolling suitcase you
just pick it up and roll it around and
you saw in the video my son was able to
at age eight to just wheel the robot
around so that was a very important
design constraint for us simple to ship
seems very prosaic but the fact that we
can put it in a cardboard box and ship
it by UPS just changes the business that
we have
albeit UPS is terrible with robots we've
had some terrible experiences there
simple to field so you can put in the
back of a car take it to a home
experiment you know the fact that you
can throw it I put in back my Prius all
the time it's just it changes what the
robot is and how you interact with it
um so that's uh Simplicity talk about
affordability again the lesson I've
gathered in getting to low cost is it
really is a systems problem
this pie chart is sort of the the cost
of of stretch as you can see it's not
one one pie wedge is is like the
dominant cost you really have to solve
all these different pie wedges
um and also there's all these hidden
costs right so the shipping cost the
warranty cost all the packaging for the
robot it just adds up and so if you're
building a low-cost product you can't
just focus on you know the actuator or
the sensor you have to think about the
whole thing
uh some some of the first work I did in
low-cost with with Professor kakoski
here at Stanford SRI this is a low-cost
hand that was done for DARPA really cool
technology packed in there so I had
Twisted string actuators so a little
piece of string you'd wind up like an
airplane rubber band it would pull on
the tendon each finger had a
electrostatic clutch so with one motor
you could do three degrees of freedom in
each finger
tactile skin capacitive encoded on the
on the fingers so super cool hand
unfortunately it didn't make it past
this prototype never got commercialized
but we we did learn a lot about kind of
developing low-cost Technologies
um but here's another take on a low-cost
hand so this is the stretch hand
and what we did is we let Amazon
crowdsource the the design by you know
we look at all the assistive Grabbers on
Amazon
you know looked at the highest rated one
you know this had thousands of reviews
said well this one must work pretty well
and so we took that added a dynamixel
Servo except for eighty dollars in
quantity one we have a we have a gripper
and it works remarkably well by the way
so
a a later project I had was a company
called Redwood robotics we're doing
collaborative robot arms you can see
here it's Force sensitive uh and this
was it was a full low-cost arm sheet
metal and belts timing belts uh strain
gauges from China that were five dollars
each uh and it worked really well we got
good Precision out of it good Force
sensitivity uh a little bit ugly in this
prototype
but um you know we're really going down
the path of can we get to a very
low-cost collaborative arm for
manufacturing and you know around the
time we were about to start
commercializing we got bought by Google
so that turned into
a project at Google that I that I led
which is these robots here that's that's
our Redwood arm it's an arm Farm they're
doing machine learning uh reinforcement
learning with the arm loading to grasp
objects
um that project unfortunately got got
shut down so we never got to the light
of day with that but but I ended up
spinning up a project that became
Everyday Robots which is a mobile
manipulation project
and you know one lesson there was that
well you can make a low-cost arm it's
not the same as a low-cost uh system
low-cost mobile manipulator and the arm
is just one component of that box so
you know with the arm we're very focused
on the transmission and getting that
cost down getting rid of harmonic drives
for example but really the whole robot
has you know so many sensors and compute
and the total cost that those gearboxes
are small in comparison
um so really you know again systems
design is what with stretch gave us a
significant cost reduction so far lower
degrees of freedom because of the
kinematic Arrangement and you can see
you know we're down here we saw it for
about twenty thousand dollars with a
good profit which means our bomb cost is
a very low because we really took the
systems approach seriously uh and in
comparison you know most other robots 5x
10x more expensive
talk a bit about capability we really
want it stretch to be useful for people
in homes we did a lot of testing a lot
of just eyes on tell operation of the
robot in homes cleaning toilets wiping
surfaces picking up toys playing games
with kids just to verify that the robot
could actually do it even with tele
operation and this is in comparison to
other manipulation platforms that are
super interesting technology but just to
me aren't credible to be in the home
anytime in the future
uh and so you know when we start at
stretch we're inspired by the PR2 which
is a fantastic platform
but you know it's very large uh it's
about 500 pounds 400 000 and it just
wasn't going to be a credible robot for
the home the thing is you can't just
shrink that robot right it doesn't won't
be a capable robot and so uh rather than
shrinking it we had to kind of rethink
what it meant for it to have our home
robot and what we came up with we can
call robot cubism right you take the
intent of a human but you're not
building a human exactly so it's sort of
a deconstructed robot we put it back
together with the systems approach in
mind
and some of the characteristics are
first off it has the reach of roughly of
a 50 percentile uh male so very good arm
reach
and by the way it scales very well so if
we made a bigger version because of that
telescoping arm for every you know inch
you add in the base width you get about
three and a half inches in reach so a
bigger version could have very very long
reach
designed to reach on countertops where
people put a lot of things we care about
manipulating
if you reach the floor and has a great
work space on the floor the PR2 could
reach the floor barely could barely
reach over its base but really we wanted
we knew we wanted to pick up stuff that
people drop right that was one of the
design considerations
uh hip width so very important in a home
to be able to navigate cluttered spaces
too often you see videos of homes that
are very wide open floor plans and no no
clutter most homes are very tight
passages very a lot of clutter so we
tried to hit the size of a Roomba uh in
terms of the base size
and finally we put some thought into
making sure we could actually do useful
tasks around people who are seated in
wheelchairs so being able to manipulate
around their face maybe it's a feeding
task and so these were the design
constraints that we went went in with
and what we came up with you can see is
very down on the left
corner here in terms of the width so it
is a Roomba size base
and the weight so it's about 25 kilo
kilograms so it really is a diff in a
different part of the design space
because it is a very different type of
type of robot
and as I mentioned we did lots of
testing in home by tell operations just
to verify that it could work
we also did a fair amount of autonomous
work to verify that it could be used in
the research Community to do things like
machine learning and so we found it to
be very capable in this regard
uh and just to highlight one bit of work
that came out of the community
um because we really do believe that the
community will be carrying this
this work forward and applying the
latest techniques particularly machine
learning this is from Carnegie Mellon uh
it's a visual imitation learning so
someone demonstrates to the robot what
to do the robot can then learn from that
and they've done about 20 different home
tasks things like turning a faucet
picking up things from the floor very
very cool work and we can't wait to see
this sort of application to stretch grow
so I'll let this play for a minute you
get a sense of types of things they can
do
okay
cool
let's see
great so finally um this notion of being
meaningful is very important to us as a
company
and uh this is sort of a project that
we've been doing the last two summers
I'll tell you about first off uh this is
work by Professor Charlie Kemp he's my
partner hello robot he spent about a
decade looking at how mobile
manipulators can be useful for people
with disabilities and what he's found in
in his work is that there really is a
real value that can be created and often
people really find it to be an enjoyable
thing to have a robot assisting them
contrary to some people's belief so it
gives us some still some work in his lab
uh we started this project with robots
for Humanity this is um
been in partnership with University of
Washington University of Illinois
and uh
this is part of the team here from two
summers ago so what we've done this is
uh funded by the NIH we spent the last
two summers working with Henry Evans
who's in bed here he's quadriplegic and
his wife Jane who's a caregiver and we
were trying to see how stretch could
actually better their their living
situation in their care situation
and so we've assembled this great team
this is the team from this last summer
uh and uh
uh University of Illinois has been
looking at human factors they're really
looking at the technology and the
acceptance of it and how to design the
interface for the robot uh Professor my
attack Max group at University of
Washington has been building that
interface that Henry uses to control the
robot and of course we've been providing
support in the robot and modifying the
robot to their needs
now one thing that we did which I think
is really
uh compelling and you don't see it often
is we have an occupational therapist on
staff
and excuse me
um and so this is
uh is trained as an occupational
therapist she did her PhD Capstone
project with us
and what occupational therapist does and
what she really advocates for is seeing
the whole person so really thinking
about their their living experience what
their hobbies are what their interests
are and spending time with them to make
sure that technology fits their needs
you know it's not a one-time
questionnaire it's really understanding
the family the Dynamics and here's you
know some some of her notes on Henry and
Jane you know he loves to play jokes he
loves to play games she loves to
exercise cook Etc so we wanted to make
sure that if we brought this technology
into their home that it met their needs
and actually improve their life
the other thing we did is we had you
know I call it an embedded roboticist so
this is Anna gabrick from uh
Northwestern she spent the summer with
us and here she's using the letterboard
which is how you can communicate with
Henry
and um but you know she's a writing
coach she's writing Ross coach she's 3D
printing parts and he's giving feedback
she's going off that night riding making
CAD printing a new part and iterating
the robot in Real Time in this and going
back another home next day and testing
it and we found the combination of the
embedded roboticist occupational
therapist to be super powerful
uh Henry by the way he has can use a
computer
so he has control of his thumb for Mouse
click and eye gaze to move a cursor and
that's his primary way of interacting
and one thing that Henry likes to remind
everyone of is what he calls the
caregiver principle
which is basically to say if the
caregiver doesn't believe in the
technology won't adopt it then it's
never going to get used right and they
have to find it easy it has to be almost
trivial for them to set up and so that's
really the gateway to this technology
adoption so in his case it's his wife
Jane and so really the robot has to make
she has to be happy with the robot as
well
um and in terms of participatory design
Henry was very Hands-On uh you know
after our first summer with him he he
developed this whole uh PowerPoint of
how he wanted the controls to be for the
next summer so Professor Chuck Max lab
went off and built that per his spec
so this last summer we did this this
exploration we did a lot of tasks I'll
touch on a few of them but they kind of
lump into social uh self-care household
care and Care partner care and so we
spent four weeks in total this summer at
his home
uh and we'll just run through some of
the videos here
's self-feeding so you can see Henry
very excited because you acted up some
food for himself right like what what a
beautiful moment and he's using the the
cursor uh to click on some buttons on
the web interface
uh and he's able to jog the joints of
the robot
and feed himself
this summer we added to the interface
ability to record scripted motions which
he had requested so just a speed speed
things up so he's very much believes uh
the speed is important for him and he
keeps pushing us make it go faster go
faster of course you know safety is a
concern and all that um
we did feeding in the wheelchair which
turned out to be a very different
problem a different part of the
workspace we had to adapt the tools to
reach up high enough firm we found
because the wheelchair can move it's
hard to register the robot to the
wheelchair and you can see there's some
blue tape on the floor which they use to
kind of set the whole thing up but just
because it could feed in bed doesn't
mean it you can feed in the wheelchair
necessarily right
um they love to play games in the family
uh card games in particular and a device
is clever way for stretch to present the
card this is a little wheelie faced guy
and I'll show you a video of them
playing poker and one thing that that
Jane said
about playing poker is that for the
first time Henry was in the flow of the
game it wasn't that that had to stop and
and you know uh facilitate him he was in
the flow of the game and it made it
natural and they could laugh they could
have fun
so you can see him presenting cards and
nodding when it's time to take it sorry
he has nothing
and I think in the next scene he gets a
pretty good hand all right
one two three four
you can spread them out a little bit
more day yeah
the facial hair really does add
something to the experience hey that's
something
oh no he's got a noise
yeah so you know they're actually
enjoying the game they're really in in
that game it's really really nice to see
um
you know we did things like like
augmenting the light switch so the
stretch could reach it better because
he's able to script a motion turn the
lights on and off
and I should say he he would record and
script these motions himself so he was
essentially programming the robot
through this interface to do this task
spent some time looking at laundry I'll
show a few videos from this uh to show
the overall concept
first
this is sort of the the sort of his
feeding towel that he has on his bed
and he's going to put it in the basket
oops the next Anna devised a way to for
stretch to toe around a little laundry
basket here and so it's clever it's a
magnetic hitch
and what it does is because the magnets
like to come apart and Shear but not in
normal uh the robot arm can go up to
disengage and back in to engage
and so it's able to Dock and this is
Henry docking in
grabbing the basket
and then here he's taking the laundry
out so he's able to drive the robot in
the car down the hallway take it to the
laundry room
and he actually took it outside someone
had to open the door but he actually
took it outside down the ramp and so
really he is in a sense participating in
the care of the home it's just something
he could never do before
and uh for Jane you know of course she
could quickly do the laundry but it was
more important that they're both
participating in the care together
uh finally something we did for Jane uh
she likes to exercise often doesn't have
the time uh because she's at home with
Henry
so Anna coded up what she called
stretcher size where for example Jane
does a sit-up Taps stretches arm the
sellerometer detects the tap counts the
sit-ups for her it gives her uh poses
that she has to reach when doing
stretches and she reported she actually
enjoyed it she actually found it fun
that it was gamified in a sense and that
she had a coach there with her
so hopefully that conveyed that you know
these robots can provide some meaningful
value into the home
and just
a final video to kind of highlight why
this all really matters uh so Henry is a
bit of a romantic uh and he wanted to
surprise Jane and so I'll show you him
uh
picking a flower and and handing it to
her her here
okay
laughs
I'm looking at dad
's
oh my gosh yeah give him time he'll
release it
look how sweet
it's so sweet oh I knew you were up to
something the way you were laughing with
me out there I was like
that is so sweet thank you so much for
making this happen oh so the funny story
is he using flowers or wasted money
and never you know it's a big waste of
money they die afterwards and now let's
do everything to them I mean all the
Roses I'll do that's him that's about
that so yeah you become a huge level
person now yeah I put this in water
Henley
okay so I think I'll wrap up with that
um some final thoughts
uh first you know I I we really do
believe this type of Technology can
provide meaningful assistance to people
who need it
um
participatory design and really
including stakeholders occupational
therapists roboticists together is very
powerful
and filing a systems thinking and
thinking about the whole problem not
just the one piece of technology
particularly in terms of safety
Simplicity affordability capability
meaningfulness is also very powerful
so with that I'll take some questions
and just want to highlight we do we're a
small company but we do hire we love
having great smart talented people
um and we're gonna have a demo of
stretch and I guess the atrium of the
d-school right after this come come
check it out and with that I'll take
some questions
[Applause]
thank you this is really exciting
um I was wondering if it's possible to
make possible and also is it desirable
to make the interface more penicillin
like I noticed that when Henry was
playing a game with his family he had to
sit facing the screen and whether that
was something that you actually wanted
or it's because he needs that much
visual input and so on too yeah yeah
so
unfortunately you know the UI right now
is large and cumbersome and and it's
hard with this robot to see uh what's
happening to get a good sense of of the
surroundings so that large screen is is
important I think it is fairly hard to
do on a smaller screen
um and we haven't tried with Henry in
particular we have tried you know
operating it from tablets and phones and
it is a real design problem to kind of
give that contextual awareness when
remote operating when your eye is on you
can see directly what's happening it's
very different than when your eyes off
and but we are also looking at in future
iteration is to add a tablet and some
other things to kind of make the UI more
natural but but for Henry he's happy
he's in front of a big screen all day
anyhow so it was fine
yep yes
hi Erin thank you for your presentation
I was particularly touched by the
reaction of people interacting with the
robots I think that was the first time
that I had that realization oh robots
can bring joy to people because I've
sometimes been biased against that
um
I'll go right ahead with a potentially
annoying question on the cyber security
side the field is very aware of
computers and data Etc I think it's
becoming more and more aware of you know
hacking your thermostat for example
admittedly inviting a robot into your
kitchen that can pick up utensils Etc
including when you're sleeping takes
that to a new level so I'm curious how
that how that is included in the
conversation you know acknowledging the
really positive sites how do we also
think perfectly about that yeah it's a
great question I don't have a good
answer for it unfortunately I mean I
think
uh you know at this stage because we are
doing experiments and it's controlled we
can manage it uh for this to become
widespread uh we do need a solution
around that one thing as a company we're
very careful about is privacy and as a
culture establishing privacy from the
get-go uh and uh I think you know I
think the best that we can do is have a
culture that values uh respecting
privacy taking security carefully but in
terms of you know preventing Hackers
from entering the robot and doing bad
things it's it's a hard problem and we
really at this stage of as being a small
company we haven't had a tackle it yet
yep
thank you Aaron very very inspiring uh
stuff uh just curious what's your path
to mass Market would you like to take it
outside of academic institutions I
suspect yeah absolutely and um you know
we are very pragmatic and understanding
about how hard it is to really to do
a robot like this in the home consumers
have very high expectations for
capability
uh they get frustrated very easily and
they want things to be very low cost so
it's almost like the hardest possible
thing you can do on top of solving the
technology right and the thing is people
like Henry are motivated to use the
device and so we do believe there's a
path with people with high leads but
it's a very small market and so I think
our our sense is
this technology can have the highest
impact if you can get it to scale
broadly in the in the broad consumer
sense uh you know I think the Apple
watch is a great example of it provides
all sorts of great things like fall
detection instead of having a
specialized device like a faulty texture
detection pendant and so I think the
path for a robot like this will be
through a broad consumer to impact
people like Henry but for us you know we
are actively trying to explore how to
take this outside of the lab and I
suspect it'll be somewhat through
Enterprise and and where we see service
commercial deployments where there's
more natural market fit and you know but
I can imagine 10 years from now that
everything is aligned in terms of the
capability of the cost Market Readiness
that this this could be in Homes at that
time
I wanted to ask you um if you uh have
found your either yourself or in
response to any feedback from from users
needing to resist having to put
um googly eyes or some sort of uh
personality uh conferring elements onto
your robot yeah
um
you know it's been remarkable it's sort
of an odd looking robot it's not uh
cuddly in a sense you know but it's the
most uh positive reactions I've ever
seen to a robot that I've worked on I've
put googly eyes on robots in the past
right but this one because of what it
can do something about the it's Slender
so it's less threatening perhaps but and
something about the the motion of the
arm people Delight in it for for some
reason and and then what it does for
people also causes delight and I think
that seems to be
more important than that sort of persona
that people often do
have you observed anybody over time
beginning to change the way they refer
to it as from it to a he or a she or
them not that but you know it is used in
a lot of uh college courses and often
students student groups they're they're
always name it and there's always a
scribe personality to their particular
stretch and I think you know maybe
that's that's part of it yeah
how do you map the degrees of freedom 2
however he is controlling it and is that
the same for everyone or is that also
part of the customizable aspect of it so
I didn't quite catch how do you how do
you map how he controls the degrees of
freedom of the robot is is that
something that is the same when you sell
different robots to different people oh
it doesn't depend on their capability
yeah yeah so so what Henry was using to
control the robot it's a web-based
interface uh it's all open source so we
released an open source version with the
robot University of Washington Forks
that code
built a whole new interface on top of
that but that is customized to him and
it's very much his iterative
um and uh you know I do think I do hope
that over time we will have a kind of
commercially ready version of that that
uh anyone can you know remotely control
the robot as we learn kind of what the
right product features are for that
remote manipulation remote navigation
but right now it very much is sort of
experiment experimental code out on
GitHub so
yeah I had a question did you have
considerations about putting a second or
making a dole arm or if not kind of
combining a multi-robot because it might
be easier to just since you settled on
the design you know have multi-agent and
what were the trade-offs you know what
tasks you now saw that it could do or
are they you know two robots could do it
yeah yeah it's a good question
um
we never considered a second arm we just
we knew from the get-go we had to keep
it as simple as we could and even I mean
we put a lot of thought into the wrist
because it as we ship it has one degree
of freedom
then we've added two more because people
want them but it turns out you can do a
lot with just one degree of freedom in
the wrist
and you can do a lot with just one arm
and our notion is it's a multi-robot
solution and you'd have this incredible
workspace with two stretches in their
arms and the bases and uh and I believe
there's there's a group um working on
that currently they have a couple
stretches but but of course it's a it's
a hard task generally to do that as you
know so
thank you for that very interesting talk
um it's okay I have two questions just
because that was a very interesting
question too I was wondering with two
orange maybe you can also uh increase
the force that you can open like doors
and things like that because you can
brace against the environment
um so I don't know maybe there's some
some value yeah
um
I guess maybe that was more of a comment
than I'm sure my question was
um
um in terms of When You Reach like Mass
Market
um what do you think is some the right
level of autonomy like at the first
maybe duration yeah it seems like it's
very capable just with collaboration
yeah but then uh robots like the Roomba
are fully autonomous so what is like a
right first approach to yeah it's a
really really tricky question uh because
today you can do a lot through tele
operation and create value today
and it's harder to to create get to that
value through autonomy today just
because it has to be robust it has to be
adaptive to failures
I think
pragmatically it's more more likely to
build a business around the autonomous
version kind of like the Roomba you buy
it out of the box you unbox you turn it
on it does something even if that
something is very simple that's an
easier business to stand up than a tele
manipulation business for example I do
think that there's real value sort of
like a telepresence robot where you can
beam in navigate around have a social
interaction and have an arm and I think
you know doing that being able to open a
door maybe if you're concerned someone
might have fallen you can open the door
and look those types of things I think
you could do in a commercial sense and
be successful
oh yeah
um
yeah Henry's a pretty unique individual
and um well controlling the robot as he
does I don't see
um very many people that would have that
same need to control it like that so I
was wondering if you're planning to do a
speech recognition interface as well
yeah and there is there is uh open
source code with the robot it has a
microphone array people have done speech
interfaces in fact we did speech
interfaces for Jane the caregiver uh
where she could essentially jog the
robot to set positions using her voice
but it's pretty clunky and rudimentary
and you know I think in the end if you
can solve the autonomy problem very hard
then the speech is a nice overlay for
that but we do find when we talk to to
people
speech is the first thing that they want
that is seems to be the interface that
seems most natural to most people
well thanks Aaron for
stretch I mean this is really a cool
design and I
discussed with you the question about
multi multi-arm and
I think you are going to need a full
wrist if you have multiple robots
working together so you can accommodate
the workspace
but uh if we keep thinking about
connecting this which like vision and
trying to to do some research I see this
as a wonderful platform for education
and I think
um probably there there would be a large
number of applications around
many new ideas that can bring increased
value to to the to the robot one robot
or multiple robots so I mean we teach at
Stanford as you know experimental
Robotics and we are always looking for
platforms like this so I'm I'm really
interested in seeing how you can take
this to Academia
what do you think yeah yes please uh but
and it is used in a number of Project
based courses Georgia Tech Carnegie
Mellon and Oregon State are all building
classes around it right now because it
is twenty thousand dollars it seems to
kind of work better in that you know our
mental model is one robot for a grad
student you know uh when I worked on Cog
large system and the whole team only had
one robot to work with and now you know
with stretch you can't imagine where uh
multiple stretches can be in a lab or in
a classroom so guys what do you think
would you like a few of these
all right yes okay thank you you haven't
ordered